[Applaudissements]
bonjour
alors je ne sais pas si vous aurez
remarqué mais nous sommes dans une
période pour le mois contradictoire
l'écologie est partout dans les
programmes politiques dans les manuels
scolaires dans le business plan des
entreprises dans les médias même dans
les publicités et pourtant la situation
n'a jamais été aussi préoccupante le
climat se réchauffe la biodiversité
s'effondre les océans sont dans un état
pitoyable les ressources épuisent et
tous les voyants nous durent absolument
rien de bon pour les années et les
décennies à venir
comment en est-on arrivé à Spa paradoxe
qu'est ce qui explique cette situation
contradictoire alors il y a de nombreux
facteurs qu'il explique certains
facteurs qui sont liés à la nature de
notre système économique d'autres
évoquent notre système politique la
démocratie serait peut-être inadéquate
pour résoudre l'urgence climatique
d'aucun et votre également le
fonctionnement de notre cerveau l'espèce
humaine serait incapable de s'auto
limiter et de vivre en équilibre avec
les équilibres environnementaux
ici moi je voudrais poser la question
est-ce que
l'écologie politique n'a-t-elle pas une
responsabilité dans cette situation
alors vous pensez bien que si je pose la
question c'est que je le pense et pour
développer mon argumentation j'aimerais
partager avec vous quatre reproches que
je ferai à l'écologie politique cette
écologie que je côtoie depuis maintenant
une vingtaine d'années à travers mes
cours puisque j'enseigne la géographie à
des lycéens à travers l'écriture parce
que je collabore un blog et j'écris des
quelques livres à travers des débats
également aussi ou des interventions
comme comme celle-ci
alors
le premier reproche que j'adresserai à
cette écologie politique dominante ce
serait premièrement un manque de courage
politique alors qu'est-ce que j'entends
par là quand on lit la majorité des
rapports en particulier les rapports
scientifiques sur toutes les questions
écologiques au sens large on voit une
focalisation sur les constats sur les
conséquences et beaucoup moins sur les
causes et les responsables alors cela et
je l'ai expérimenté plusieurs fois avec
des débats avec des climatologues par
exemple on me répond systématiquement
voilà nous sommes des scientifiques et
donc il faut être neutre il faut être
objectif scientifiquement mais quand on
y réfléchit est-ce vraiment manqué
d'objectivité de considérer que notre
système économique appelons le
capitalisme et la cause majeure des
déséquilibres écologiques de notre
planète ça a été prouvé maintes et
maintes fois par différents auteurs
est-ce que c'est manqué d'objectivité
scientifique quand on évoque le poids la
responsabilité des principales
multinationales en particulier
pétrolières minières gazières etc dans
la catastrophe climatique que nous
traversons et se manquait d'objectivité
de simplement admettre que la nature
profonde de notre système économique qui
est de produire toujours plus consommer
toujours plus transporter toujours plus
de choses et fondamentalement
incompatible avec les conclusions de
l'ensemble des rapports scientifiques
qui nous disent explicitement ou
implicitement qu'ils font produire moins
consommer moins
et transporter moins
deuxième
reproche que j'adresserai à cette
écologie dominante c'est la
culpabilisation on vous a certainement
par les médias par les différentes
associations invitées à changer vos
comportements individuels on se focalise
beaucoup quand on parle d'écologie sur
les comportements individuels il faut
absolument que nous consommons moins de
viande que nous éteignons notre langue
que nous prenions moins notre voiture
etc etc etc alors évidemment ces gestes
sont encouragés je pense que tout le
monde sera d'accord ici mais
viendrait-il à l'idée quand quelqu'un
dans cette salle de vider une piscine
avec une cuillère
pourtant c'est de ce sens de proportion
c'est dans ce sens de proportion dans
cette proportion que nous sommes quand
on parle de geste individuel et
d'ailleurs l'association un bureau
d'étude français qui s'appelle carbone 4
à chiffrer l'importance de ces
comportements individuels et à imaginer
que si l'ensemble des Français aurait
adopteraient un adopté pardon un
comportement vertueux écologiquement
seul un quart du chemin à parcourir
serait fait et donc les trois quarts
restants dépendent de politique beaucoup
plus large et de changements qui
dépassent l'individu
mais plus grave encore cette
focalisation sur les gestes individuels
elle occulte le fait que nombre de ses
gestes dépendent d’infini de politique
beaucoup plus large qui nous dépasse
également en tant qu'individu
comment moindre moins prendre sa voiture
quand depuis 50 ans l'aménagement du
territoire que ce soit en Belgique en
France ou dans la plupart des pays est
totalement organisé en fonction de cette
automobile c'est-à-dire où on a ce qu'on
appelle un zona urbain dans lequel
chaque fonction du quotidien se situe
dans un territoire différent ce qui nous
contraint à parcourir des dizaines voire
des centaines de kilomètres par jour
quand il y en a une centralisation de
l'emploi dans les villes quand on a on a
promis pendant des dizaines d'années un
étalement urbain via des lotissements
individuels quand on désinvestit encore
aujourd'hui dans les transports publics
via la fermeture de gare via la
fermeture de petites lignes etc etc
autre exemple comment consommer moins
quand nous sommes
harcelés disons le franchement des
dizaines voire des centaines de fois par
jour par des publicités jouant sur nos
réflexes biologiques les plus primaires
nous invitons à consommer toujours plus
troisième exemple comment peut-on
imaginer que une partie de la population
se préoccupe des enjeux futurs quand
leurs conditions matérielles ne leur
pètent même pas de vivre dignement au
quotidien
comme disait un célèbre slogan qui est
devenu célèbre dans les différentes
manifestations de gilets jaunes avant la
fin du monde et à la fin du mois
troisième reproche que j'adresserai à
cette écologie politique c'est un
certain négocentrisme qu'est-ce que
j'entends par là c'est à dire une
incapacité chez nombre de théoriciens de
l'écologie politique à voir la véritable
écologie chez les classes populaires et
à l'inverse de se focaliser sur des
comportements qui sont deux facteurs
réservés au plus privilégié d'entre nous
on nous invite constamment à installer
des panneaux solaires à rénover sa
maison à consommer hors des supermarchés
à acheter une voiture électrique à faire
de l'écotourisme quand bien même cela se
fait à l'autre bout du monde
et quand on regarde réfléchit tous ces
comportements sont systématiquement
réservés à aux personnes qui en ont les
moyens et donc sont vus par une partie
de la population a juste titre à mon
avis comme un luxe et c'est un double
tort parce que ces classes populaires
elles auraient à l'inverse beaucoup à
nous apprendre quand tu as une véritable
écologie populaire puisque ces classes
populaires souvent elles ont une
empreinte même si elles ont une
conscience environnementale moins élevée
elles ont souvent une empreinte
écologique bien moins élevée également
elles vivent dans des moins grandes
maisons elles prennent moins l'avion
elles ont tendance à consommer moins de
choses etc etc
à cet égard je voulais attirer votre
attention j'ai parlé des gilets jaunes
tout à l'heure le mouvement des gilets
jaunes j'espère je pense que la plupart
d'entre vous s'en rappelle le
déclenchement du mouvement des gilets
jaunes donc c'était une hausse des taxes
sur le carburant qui a mis le feu aux
poudres une partie de la population en
particulier vivant dans les zones
rurales et étant très dépendant de la
voiture et on les a un peu notamment
dans de nombreux médias ou même dans
certains discours publics on les a pris
plus ou moins explicitement comme bah
des gens qui s'en foutaient un peu de
l'écologie des amoureux de leur bagnole
voire dans certains cas ils ont le
franchement de plouc de des campagnes or
quand on y réfléchit et quand on regarde
de plus près les revendications des
gilets jaunes bien qu'hétérogènes elle
portait un certain nombre de
renversations tout à fait intéressantes
pour un programme d'écologie politique
ça prenait notamment une redynamisation
des campagnes via l'arrêt de la
fermeture des services publics de
proximité les maternités les écoles les
services de gare il prenait un arrêt de
la centralisation
urbaine et de de redistribution des
richesses entre le territoire il prenait
également l'arrêt des délocalisation la
récréation d'un tissu industriel en
France qui éviterait d'importer des
choses des quatre coins du monde bref
toute une série de mesures qui
pourraient parfaitement s'inscrire dans
un véritable programme d'écologie et
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas on
pourrait dire avec un peu provocation
que le seul tort des gilets jaunes à cet
égard c'est d'avoir opté pour la couleur
jaune s'il avait peut-être opté par des
gilets verts pour des géants les choses
auraient peut-être été autrement
quatrième
reproche que j'adresserai à cette
écologie politique dominante c'est la
déconnexion la déconnexion justement
avec certaines réalités sociales qui
concerne une partie de la population
cette décision cette déconnexion elle
s'explique notamment à mon sens par une
intellectualisation à outrance de la
question écologique dans laquelle on a
des théoriciens qui débattent de sujets
à mon sens totalement anecdotique et qui
ne parle absolument pas aux classes
populaires au monde ouvrier aux classes
syndicales au monde agricole aux
habitants des quartiers populaires des
villes c'est-à-dire des questions sur où
on va culpabiliser les gens qui font des
barbecues qui achètent un sapin de Noël
qui vont participer autour de France
bref toute une série de mesures qui sont
complètement anecdotiques et qui
reviennent à ce sentiment de
culpabilisation ou ces fameuses classes
populaires se sente dépossédés si on
veut de leur capacité
à agir
sur ce point
alors
ces reproches que j'adresserai que
j'adresse à l'écologie politique en
toute bienveillance malgré peut-être le
fait que j'adopte un brin un côté un peu
provocateur puisque je fais partie en
fait de cette écologie politique en tout
cas je considère en faire partie le but
ici n'est absolument pas de de
diaboliser ou de provoquer des attaques
personnelles d'ailleurs si vous regardez
dans ma dans mon petit développement il
y a aucun il y a aucun nom il y a pas de
nom de personnalité il y a pas nom de
parti mais l'idée est plutôt de
provoquer une remise en question
profonde chez la plupart des gens qui se
revendiquent de l'écologie politique
la journaliste Naomi Klein a affirmé que
le changement social survient quand la
frontière s'estompe entre le monde
militant et le reste de la population
si l'on veut parvenir à ça il faut
absolument que les tenants d'une
écologie politique parviennent à un
projet d'écologie populaire j'ai essayé
de vous le démontrer et également
d'écologie sociale ce projet ne pourra
devenir populaire que si en plus de
d'adopter des politiques qui nous
rendent qui rendent notre notre vie
quotidienne compatible avec labilité
pardon de la planète nous
contribue également à une amélioration
concrète des conditions matérielles dans
lequel vivent une population ce projet
il n'est pas théorique il peut s'appuyer
sur différents piliers que vous
connaissez tous et ces piliers
nécessitent des politiques qui sont
relativement faciles à mettre en oeuvre
comme le développement de service public
de qualité non seulement l'éducation la
santé mais également le logement les
transports l'énergie la finance ce
programme politique il pourrait
s'appuyer également par une réduction
massive du temps de travail puisque on
sait que une majorité des gens c'est un
luxe également de s'impliquer dans sa
localité de s'impliquer écologiquement
de faire ses courses dans des magasins
de proximité on sait que c'est des
choses qui sont réservées aux gens qui
ont le temps on pourrait également et on
devrait également envisager des
politiques donc qui sont à la fois
écologiques et sociales c'est-à-dire qui
vise à tout prix en priorité à une
redistribution des richesses on peut
prendre comme exemple des politiques de
taxation progressives qui feraient que
l'ensemble de la population ne paierait
pas le mètre cube d'eau le même prix en
fonction de celui qui utilise ces mètres
cubes d'eau pour se laver et pour ses
besoins quotidiens et une autre personne
qui utiliserait ses maîtres cubes d'eau
pour remplir sa piscine bref toute une
série de mesures qui ont déjà été
élaborés ailleurs mais qui sont vraiment
fondamentales
comme je dis tout à l'heure si on veut
produire moins consommer moins il faudra
inévitablement partager plus c'est pour
ça que la redistribution des richesses
doit être au cœur d'un projet d'écologie
politique si l'on veut que ce projet
soit social et je terminerai par une
citation d'un militant écologiste
brésilien qui a été malheureusement
assassiné pour ses convictions dans les
années 80 qui s'appliquent
et qui affirmait l'écologie sans lutte
des classes ce n'est pas de l'écologie
c'est du jardinage je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]